What is the most dangerous
creature in the universe?
Here on planet Earth there are creatures that have
hardly evolved since prehistoric eras like sharks,
crocodiles, and snakes… perfect biological
killing machines. But then again, the animal
kingdom is nothing when compared to the menagerie
of creatures contained by the SCP Foundation.
So, once again, what is the most dangerous
creature in the universe? Is it SCP-682?
The damage regenerating reptile with a hatred
for all other forms of life? Or is it The Scarlet
King? Or is the Broken God more deserving of that
title? Maybe the answer still lies elsewhere, and
thankfully, there is one SCP in the Foundation’s
archives that might not be the most dangerous
itself, but teaches us a very important lesson
about what the most dangerous entity truly is.
This is the story of SCP-001, The Spiral Path.
An important distinction, before we go any
further: SCP-001 doesn’t refer
to a single creature, object,
or entity, but rather a collection of various
anomalies contained by the SCP Foundation.
It is unclear why there are multiple files
collected under the shared designation of SCP-001.
Some believe these anomalies are some of the
earliest ever contained by the Foundation,
encountered before they introduced
their current numbering system.
There is also the theory that this is intentional
misdirection, that the multiple SCP-001 files
are an attempt by the Foundation to conceal
secret information about the true SCP-001.
Anomalies sharing the name SCP-001 include
the infamous, aforementioned Scarlet King,
a powerful eldritch being intent on ending
all creation. Another anomalous being with
similar levels of destructive power is the Gate
Guardian, believed to be an angel standing at the
entrance to the Garden of Eden, it too goes by the
name SCP-001. But, for the purposes of this video,
we will be using SCP-001 to refer to something
otherwise codenamed The Spiral Path. And while it
is not a creature in and of itself, SCP-001 does
yield one answer to that important question: What
is the most dangerous creature in the universe?
On paper, SCP-001 does not seem to be much,
and it certainly doesn’t appear to be any
sort of threat. As its nickname suggests,
The Spiral Path is exactly that. Located
deep in a wooded area known only as Site 0,
SCP-001 is a gravel path in the shape of a spiral.
Your first thought at hearing that might be,
“what could be so important about a path?”
If someone were to find themselves walking
along The Spiral Path, traveling clockwise around
the gravel, then they will find that… nothing
happens. It’s just a normal path with slight
inclines and declines as one traverses it. If
one should walk counterclockwise around it though,
then they will begin to experience SCP-001’s first
anomalous effect. The path will begin to feel
as if it is sloping uphill, getting steeper and
steeper. When they reach the beginning of the path
again, a person will still as if they are walking
endlessly uphill. All this while, the path itself
does not move or change in form or altitude.
To put it simply, walking one way around SCP-001
causes it to behave normally. Walking the other,
the path does not adhere to the laws of physics.
You may well be thinking, “is that all?” On a
surface level, The Spiral Path does appear
to be just an unmoving, low-threat anomaly.
While it may not be as aggressive or malicious
as some of the SCP Foundation’s rogues gallery,
it is still a spatial anomaly that defies all
Euclidean geometry. That might sound like small
potatoes when compared to everything the SCP
Foundation has faced over the years. But bear in
mind, if The Spiral Path is truly SCP-001, and the
very first anomaly that the Foundation learned of,
then a simple path that ignores the ordinary
laws of space and time would have been a major
discovery in the organization’s earliest days.
But why would they still keep The Spiral Path
so heavily guarded all these years later?
SCP-001 is kept behind a maximum security
fence that has been constructed all the way around
the perimeter of Site 0. At all times, the SCP
Foundation keeps no less than five fully armed
members of security personnel on site to keep
watch over The Spiral Path and make sure that no
one approaches it who isn’t authorized to. There
is a small metal plaque too, bearing an unknown
inscription on it. Special Containment Procedures
for SCP-001 state that this plaque is to be kept
in good condition, and it should be immediately
reported if it shows any signs of damage.
A Foundation physics laboratory is also located
nearby, where research staff tirelessly
conduct scientific tests on SCP-001
and its anomalous properties. So, there’s
definitely something more to The Spiral Path
than a simple stroll around it would tell you.
Attached to SCP-001’s file is an item referred
to as Document 001-O5. Written by high ranking
Foundation researcher Doctor Everett Mann,
any prospective or new members of the O5
Council are required to read this document and,
from the events it details, learn the truth.
Not just the truth about The Spiral Path,
but the truth about the SCP Foundation itself.
Doctor Mann begins this file by explaining to
the reader that either he or one of the original
founders of the SCP Foundation must have died,
and the person reading has been appointed as a
successor. Whether his death was caused by an SCP,
an operative from another anomalous organization
like the Global Occult Coalition, or “getting
a little close to the flame”, Mann states that
old age definitely wouldn’t be what killed him.
He writes, “We took care of that, didn’t we?”
Whether he means that he and the rest of the
“old guard” are somehow immortal, or just
working for the Foundation would likely
mean dying before reaching old age, is unclear.
But, Doctor Mann’s next statement is one that
changes the very way we view the Foundation
and its entire purpose. “We have never
‘discovered’ an SCP in the entire history of
the Foundation.” According to Document 001-O5,
every instance of an anomalous creature,
entity or object, is entirely staged.
He then goes on to describe Aaron Siegel, a gifted
physicist that Doctor Mann regarded very highly.
“I believe that his name would be there with
Edison, Einstein, and Hawking. I knew him very
well. He was, and may still be, my brother.”
The pair evidently shared a close personal
connection, and it was Siegel who first discovered
SCP-001. During a hike, Aaron stumbled upon The
Spiral Path, noticing that no matter how far
uphill he seemed to travel, his elevation
never once changed, only for him to end up back
at the start of the path. Being a physicist,
Siegel quickly realized how this unassuming
gravel path did not conform to Euclidean geometry,
that it did not fit within the laws of nature.
Constructing a small wooden shack nearby,
Aaron Siegel began to study the properties of
The Spiral Path. Equation after equation, hours
spent examining every variable and experimenting
with his findings. Until something unforeseen
happened: Aaron created an SCP, a key that had
the innate ability to open any lock. Nowadays,
that same key is still in the Foundation’s
possession, under the designation SCP-005.
Slowly, Aaron began to bring others into the fold,
trusted colleagues and other scientific minds.
Among them was, of course, Doctor Everett Mann,
who was still a medical student at Harvard at the
time. This brain trust, a think tank composed of
only a select few, they were the very beginning.
The ones who founded the SCP Foundation.
Using their own fortunes and funding from
Thomas Carter, the group continued with Siegel’s
experiments. The scientists had high hopes for
what they could achieve, planning to change
the world for the better. Feeding the hungry,
providing shelter to the homeless, curing
the sick, and even cheating death itself.
In the beginning, this proto-Foundation started
small. Their goals were noble, but could not
realistically be achieved overnight. They tried
to make items that would improve life, such as a
fountain of youth, a partially sentient Civil War
statue, and an extremely bouncy ball. Better known
to the Foundation today as SCP-006, SCP-011 and
SCP-018 respectively. But then this new Foundation
began to grow, with more organization and a
secret facility. And with that expansion, came
emboldened scientists, eager to change the world.
The group began working on human test subjects,
volunteers and drifters that soon became SCPs.
The Spiral Path was not just a break in the
fabric of reality. In a metaphorical sense, it
referred to the spiraling path the newly formed
Foundation itself was on. Every discovery they
made led to another, and that to another still.
Until things started to go wrong. During the
continuing experiments, Dr Mann created SCP-008,
a deadly zombie plague capable of infecting
anyone with one hundred percent lethality. More
and more of the founders were so invested in their
projects, that the results were often nightmarish.
The Foundation needed help, that came when
Thomas Carter showed their work to the military
in exchange for additional funding and personnel.
The SCP Foundation expanded even further, becoming
an international organization and bringing in
new researchers and staff. In some instances,
the founders would arrange for the anomalies they
had created to be “found” by the new recruits,
other times they would fabricate reports,
changing the details of how things like SCP-008
or the fountain of youth were first discovered.
Anything the founders said was simply now a fact,
no one questioned them.
Even then, problems still arose.
Founding members broke away from the SCP
Foundation, some even creating splinter
groups that would later become infamous Groups
of Interest. The Foundation’s directive shifted,
now focusing on the containment of anomalies,
as yet more were created through darker means.
SCP-231 was taken from an orphanage, Doctor Mann
himself vivisected a small boy who then became
SCP-610, the Flesh That Hates. And there
were more still; Abel, the blood pond,
and even the Hard To Destroy Reptile. All of
them were the creation of the Foundation itself.
But through it all, Doctor Mann wrote, he was
never afraid of the path that the Foundation was
on. He was never even afraid of all the monsters
and abominations that he and the other founders
had secretly created by studying SCP-001. What
truly scared him were the anomalies the Foundation
didn’t create. There were some that would just
appear in containment one day, even if they hadn’t
been there before. They would seem like they had
always been there. Doctor Mann closes Document
001-O5 with the realization that he and the other
founders simply were not in control anymore.
The tale of Doctor Mann and the other founders of
the SCP Foundation is one of noble intentions that
ultimately became corrupted. At first, the
founders created SCPs that they hoped would
benefit humanity. But then came the mistakes,
the accidents, the monsters, like SCP-008,
SCP-610, and even SCP-682. The Foundation lied
to the governments and militaries of the world,
claiming they’d found these SCPs - not
created them - and in return, they received
funding and staff to expand, allowing the SCP
Foundation to grow to become what it is today.
Dr Mann posits that at this point, the
Foundation was no longer in control,
but perhaps they never were.
And all of this stems back from one,
singular starting point: The Spiral Path. It
might be impossible to truly know how many
anomalies and SCPs the Foundation created, just
from researching SCP-001. Only the O5 Council
will ever know exactly how many of the founders’
discoveries they themselves were responsible for.
And now you know the answer to what’s the
most dangerous creature in the universe.
It’s regular people, dabbling with something
they could never hope to fully understand.
Starting with the hope to change the world, only
to create monsters that might one day destroy it.
Now go check out “SCP-001 -
Which is the Real 001?” and
“SCP-001 - The Scarlet King” for more
on the legendary SCP-001 designation!